what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar and it's been a minute since my
last one punch man review but so many
insane stuff is happening right now in
the story that it's about time to talk
about it we're talking awakened
confirmed god threat level garo blast
getting serious saitama getting serious
and much more so make sure to stay tuned
for this one serious punch that like
button if you do enjoy seeing these one
punch man chapter reviews i want to keep
them coming subscribe and hit that
notification bell if you haven't so you
don't miss future one punch man chapter
reviews and updates because it is
getting really good right now and now
without further ado let's jump into his
spoilers and all so we start off with
garo after getting the power up from god
but not falling completely under his
control and garo is making everyone
around him fall apart by just being
there child emperor gets a nosebleed and
then collapses his hair is falling out
bang notices that there's something in
garo that's not garo something evil it's
bang's opinion that garo is being
controlled bang wants garo back but garo
calmly tells him he's in his right mind
and exercising his own free will then
blast number one s-class hero appears so
hype i love it whenever this man makes
an appearance he says bang is right and
garu is being controlled by god he
explains that garo was given divine
energy another hype detail looks like
garo has god ki now then blast is
something big that any attack garu
unleashes while on the planet could
endanger the very existence of all
living things that is literally the
definition of a god-level threat which
is defined as a threat that endangers
the survival of all humanity it can't
get any more conclusive than that since
now even without trying to garo can take
out all living things not just humanity
he's become disaster level god as he's
always wanted to blast tries to reason
with him asking does the endangering of
all living things line up with garo's
goals garu actually doesn't dismiss him
but asks if that's true what should he
do to which blast suggests that he'll
lead him to another dimension he tells
him to take a look at the effect he's
having on everyone and we see that
almost everyone can't tolerate the
cosmic radiation garu is giving off the
effect is reminiscent of conqueror's
hockey from one piece where the
low-level characters are just taken out
from the get-go of course blast has
resistance to it but he explains the
others will die just from garo being
here now that is quite an insane level
of power blast notices now that garo
does retain some humanity and wonders if
he managed to stave off the full
impartation of god's power if so blast
fears what would happen if god's full
impartation of power was complete blast
is then about to utter some very hype
words literally all we're missing right
now is saitama showing up and getting
serious and we'll get that later in the
chapter 2 but not yet the hype thing
blast says is if garo won't listen to
reason then it'll be a battle of
supremacy between two beings who
manipulate the reality of the cosmos to
decide who is right and who is wrong
we're learning a lot about blast here
including the fact that he understands
the importance of power no matter what
at the end of the day the stronger will
ultimately have the privilege of
choosing who is right aka of making
themselves right might makes right if
you will it's also hype how they're
represented as divine like beings who
can manipulate the reality of the cosmos
and i realize i might be saying hype a
lot in this chapter review but it was a
very hyped chapter although we all know
saitama will beat his opponents in the
end getting to see awaken garo push
blast to his limit would be amazing garo
laughs saying divine power ain't bad at
all just him being around means that
he's finally getting to be the symbol of
fear he always wanted to be he's still
aligned with his goal even if it means
he can't be close to others he finally
proclaims he is that miserable future
disaster level god and yeah i don't
really think anyone can question that
disaster level anymore it makes you
think though how strong is this god
figure himself if he can make others so
powerful bang tries to interfere with
garo but blast tells him to stop since
if he gets closer he'll only die i love
bang's attitude here though he's just
like so what i love that zorro-like
contempt for death all the while garo
contemplates evil how no one needs to
understand it how people are miserable
if they are around it he's tried to
convince himself to finish off bang and
to never see the kid who looks up to him
again it's a recurring idea to shone and
you gotta cut all ties off if you wish
to reach your goal like sasuke and
naruto but as we know people with that
ideology usually get knocked to their
senses sooner or
jenos later in with the headbutt he's in
no condition to fight but he keeps
fighting because he's not affected by
the radiation either nice touch there
since it makes sense that he would be
less effected as a cyborg plus what is
about to happen because of this genos
intervention just makes the chapter so
much crazier garo calls him heroic and
mentions the fact that it makes sense
that he was saitama student despite his
s-class ranking blast then uses a really
cool move called dimension cannon he
fires it off but garo sees fit to avoid
it as garo mentions it's a force
transfer aka i assume it would teleport
people to another place or dimension if
it touched them like kamui shuriken from
naruto but enough naruto references the
fight becomes like the dr strange film i
watched yesterday blast uses circular
portals to teleport garo from place to
place while delivering high speed
gravity punches it's definitely epic to
see what blast is finally capable of and
it is not disappointing finally it looks
like blast one he teleports garo away
but garo is progressing so fast he is
able to copy the ability and teleport
back he pretty much copies blast's moves
including his gravity punches blast uses
teleportation rings to protect himself
from the punches but eventually they
burst from the overload of energy and
blast is shocked to see it blast
realizes that if this much power keeps
being unleashed here the planet will die
he then decides he'll need to transfer
everyone else out which is the only
solution if garo can just come back
whenever he wants garo then talks big
first he praises blast saying that it
makes sense he's the number one s-class
hero which yeah he rocked but then he
says he's still not worth garo's
attention that's how strong garrow has
become at least in his own opinion i'm
sure blast has more abilities up his
sleeves but it definitely seems like
garo's got the advantage so far garo
ignores blast and then destroys genos to
bring out saitama's true strength it's
crazy and gets a lot darker than i
expected we appear to have a full black
page here which i'm guessing will be in
the official release too and it is a
nice touch to symbolize the gravity of
the moment it begins to rain probably
part rain part geno's liquids and
saitama is here we've never seen him
snap like this before garo points out
that saitama was too late to save his
friend garo passes saitama what used to
be genos core and we see a brutal image
of generous lifeless body that we're not
even gonna show for youtube reasons this
could be saitama's krillin getting
killed moment he just doesn't have the
hair to go super saiyan but otherwise
this could be crazy he remembers a
conversation with genos about hiro
timing and how he usually arrives too
late just like right now saitama thinks
to himself it sure doesn't look like he
has a hero's intuition and then we see
his serious face he launches a killer
series serious punch the expression the
gravity conveyed through the
illustration it's all amazing garo
copied saitama by entering saitama mode
and launching his own similar attack
blast the number one s-class hero who
was hyped for so long is now petrified
knowing that this energy will shatter
the earth if their fists collide and
that is the end of this epic chapter
arguably the best chapter of one punch
man ever we got blast getting serious
awakened garo getting serious even
saitama finally snapping and losing it
after watching his best friend get
destroyed right in front of his eyes by
garo the darkness in this one was
definitely unlike most one punch man
chapters so i really can't wait to see
what happens next what does a saitama
who has snapped and doesn't hold back
look like let me know your thoughts on
the chapter and what you expect to
happen in the next one it seems like
blast will have to get saita mangaro out
of this dimension and then the two can
go wild against each other and that will
probably be some of the best fighting
illustrations we've seen so far but for
now smash that like button with your own
serious punch if you enjoyed this review
and want to keep them coming you
definitely don't want to miss the next
chapter review which is looking to be
even crazier than this one with
saitama's serious power at full display
so subscribe and hit that notification
bell if you haven't so you don't miss
future one punch man chapter reviews and
updates while you wait for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my one punch man playlist that includes
videos on all s class heroes dragon and
god level monsters and more link to that
is in the description and until next
time see ya space cowboys